We're going to switch gears for
just a minute and
focus on what a Swift file
looks like in context.
Here's a very simple Xcode project
from the UI Kit Fundamentals course.
Ignore the code for now.
I just want you to notice the files
over here in the project navigator.
You can see here that there's
a .swift file for the AppDelegate,
there's a .swift file for
the ViewController, and
here in the center you see
the ViewController.swift file opened.
Now, if you're accustomed to
writing code in Java or C,
you might be wondering
where is the header file?
The implementation files and interface
files are not separated in Swift.
There's just one .swift file
in which a class is defined.
You might be wondering, if there's
not a separate interface file,
then how do you know which objects
are public and which are private?
In Swift the default access
control is internal.
Which is similar to protected in Java.
In general, with simple apps, you can
use an object with internal access from
anywhere in the app, but
not outside the app.
Practically speaking, this means that
sometimes we'll need to specify a class
as private, but rarely will we
need to specify a class as public.